mais d'abord on rentre si vous êtes
d'accord dans la chair des choses
puisqu'on va parler de choses sérieuses
mais toujours avec un autre regard je me
rappelle on vous a beaucoup beaucoup
parlé de la rentrée des classes c'est
vrai c'était l'information de la semaine
qui se termine dans la rentrée des
classes vous savez tout savais qu'il y
avait treize millions d'élèves qui avait
700 mille professeurs qui ont des
problèmes ou pas de problème vous êtes
au courant de tout ça on a peu parlé de
ce qui est peut-être le plus importante
pour les enfants pour beaucoup de
parents ou si important que le cartable
neuf ou le stylo bille ce sont les
larmes de nos enfants alors on va parler
des larmes de nos enfants de leur peur
de leurs craintes
on va le faire sérieusement les en
souriant quand même et pour commencer un
petit florilège on pourrait appeler ça
histoire des larmes à travers 40 ans
d'école les actualités françaises à
venir entendre pour la première fois
depuis six ans les enfants vont
apprendre à lire sans redouter le bruit
des sirènes ou le fracas des bombes
il faut que ce petit monde grandissent
et s'instruisent en paix
si on va tout donner pour fois epoupa et
le et ses discours